a two-parter for this one because i do
know
what the outcome wound up being but i
was very curious about your experience
shooting
the this is your brain on drugs psa
because
for the for the first part of this
question here from from an outsider
perspective
i look at something like that and i'm
like oh like you just go in and get it
done it's not the same type of heavy
lifting as making a film but like that
psa
requires i think what might have been a
little more from you so
what was it like kind of nailing that
shoot and how did you approach it as an
actor
first of all i really appreciate that
you picked up on that because
something like a psa isn't just walking
in
and making a more serious face and
saying several lines and doing this and
that you really want to feel like
you gave to the people who put weeks and
you know maybe months of prep into
making a thing uh you just get to show
up and sort of
run the ball across the end zone or
whatever sports metaphor
and allergies fits here i'm so so dumb
about that but
you know it's it's fun to be there you
know
for part of the for part of completion
but i really feel a great sense of
um duty to the people who have put a lot
into it and
it was really it was incredibly
meaningful
to me to be able to reprise my role in
that psa
given what history has taught us about
structural
racism mass incarceration and the
ultimately uh pretty
disastrous quote-unquote war on drugs do
you remember
the time like at what point after making
the original psa
did that click for you and then i don't
know was there
was there any apprehension because it
could be a scary situation to kind of
step up and make that point especially
for such a well-known series of psas so
i don't know did you have to build the
courage to kind of put that out there
and put your voice to it
this is one of the millions of americans
who uses drugs
and won't get arrested however
this american is several times more
likely to be charged with a drug crime
imagine it's you the only reason i
hesitated about saying yes to it
immediately was that
i wasn't as well educated as i could
have been about
um what seemed to be the
the impetus behind making it in the
first place which was
hey we need to legalize cannabis in all
forms you know in all 50 states
like right now and i just didn't
i was just like i don't have all of the
information on this you know what i mean
like
why am i the i i didn't want to be
the just saying no to drugs you know
girl but i didn't want to
have that spun into the say yes to weave
girl thanks i'm just i'm i'm not a weird
person that just
me and that just don't go together so i
i felt
reticent about joining the campaign for
a moment but then
i remember um you know hearing about eva
duvernay's
13th and i saw that and it completely
uh pulled me over and taught me things
that
i was afraid i knew but sort of you know
really uh communicated them in
technicolor to me
and i was really glad we've been part of
the piece which we had just shot pretty
recently so i'm sorry that's my very
long-winded answer on that i think it's
a good story to share because i think
that a lot of people are in that
position
right now where you know they might have
been
misinformed on certain things before and
it can be hard to kind of
you know maybe admit you're wrong and
grow and try to find a new path to
uh discussing something and like your
little version of that right there is a
pretty powerful one
no i i so appreciate that and what's
strange is that like
yes the the original psa was paid for by
partnership for a drug-free america and
got splashed across the cover of
newspapers all over the country
of here is you know here's i end up sort
of the face of the war on drugs for a
little while but truthfully
the copy to that psa reads
don't do heroin which i think we can all
agree is still a pretty
non-controversial statement